Oh
[Music]
are you a slave yes every human being is
a slave but the question is to whom or
what are you a slave to your job which
dictates that the next project has to be
finished by X date and time therefore
you work the 14-hour days to finish it
or are you a slave to the current trend
which dictate who is fashionable and
what isn't and you follow that blindly
or are you a slave to yourself eating
whatever you like drinking whatever you
like doing whatever you like without any
limit consider this true freedom can
only be obtained by being a slave to the
one who gave you life the one who will
bring you today the one who gives you
the air to breathe food to eat and like
to see what the one who created you from
nothing and created everything around
you and said in a balance in harmony
God Almighty says in the Quran I have
not created the spirits and human beings
except to worship me that's in the Quran
chapter 51 I of 56 the word worship
above is a rough translation the Arabic
word Nevada which not only includes
praise glorification and appreciation of
God which is what we typically think of
when we hear the word worship but also
obedience to God like this all the noble
prophets and messengers of God including
Noah Abraham Moses Jesus and Mohammed
being define on the last peace be upon
them all were slaves of God praising
Lord funds and thanking him along with
doing what he ordered and staying away
from what he prohibited they all
submitted themselves completely to him
that's what a Muslim is any peaceful
person who has submitted themselves to
God the only religion that calls for
this complete submission to the Creator
not his creation in place of submission
to his creation in Islam as a matter of
fact the word Islam means submission
worshipping the Creator alone who not
his creation so you have two choices
either be a slave to the creation or be
a slave to the Creator and submit
yourself to him like all of his noble
prophets and messengers did hope this
got you thinking take the first step and
start asking sincerely for guidance from
your Creator thank you don't forget to
share and like this video subscribe and
do your best to help the D show reach
its goal thank you very much Salaam
alaikum peace be with you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]